so of course we start with Isis and Isis
in her initiation what's happening there
is Isis helps us clear a lot of Oaths
and vows for some of us thousands of
lifetimes of you know we we pick up a
lot of wounding along the path of having
a soul and we make a lot of agreements
that keep us small instead of in our
full power
um to other species to other lifetimes
to other religious agreements that would
keep us from being in our full Sovereign
power so when we're stepping into a
mentorship with Isis where she's helping
us get really serious about the truth
that we're extremely powerful and how to
get sober from
um our fears about that and how to fully
like embrace it Isis for me is all about
like stepping in Your Divine Purpose
your message your offering
um getting important projects completed
also knowing that you can be in your
power with your your in the center of
your family structure and your
relationship
whether you're a partnership especially
but also how you relate to others
um
she's
she's very relationship oriented because
she knows that relationships are how
anything gets done here on the Earth
plane so she's gonna help you look at
all the ways that you might be afraid to
relate to others which could help you
step more into your power
really interesting yeah and she's also
extremely glamorous so a lot her along
with Mary Magdalene they're great
mentors for reclaiming the divine
feminine like adorning yourself loving
your body Letting Go shame conditioning
um you know being in your full feminine
yeah I feel feminine and this is for men
too it's just she she's really a mentor
for how you present yourself to the
world and then it's safe to be powerful
hot Thor we take a pretty significant
jump with that horror
Isis was one of hathor's greatest
initiates and um Hawthorne created a
mystery school when she walked the Earth
that spanned half the planet
yeah so when we're when we're talking
about where's your school um everywhere
yeah so you know when Heather walked the
Earth
um we're we are living uh in a different
kind of potential
um you could call it an extreme golden
age and hathor took that golden age to
an entirely new level you know in the
Sofia code we share how she was at her
Mystery Schools hosting
um ceremonies and initiations with
teachers from the serious star system
they were shape-shifting to reveal
Humanity's full potential to shapeshift
themselves and use their DNA like that
form is actually quite pliable well we
really are Just Energy we're just yeah
so you know her teachings are all about
our Quantum potential and and really in
the Sofia code what you're doing is
um she's the one initiation where we're
quite consciously it's happening in
every initiation but she spells it out
you actually activate the bridges of
light from the Bridget from the edges of
your DNA the ladders of your DNA to the
Divine genome and the subatomic Universe
of your DNA so I had to really go deep
with hathor to understand these Divine
genome teachings that the cephea code
presents and actually
um I just had the most amazing
conversation with uh
yeah oh my God he's so brilliant he
actually had information that I had seen
that a channel that's so cool
I don't know he owns a company called
the DNA company yes you can get your
basically your DNA read to like what
pathways are open closed how your
hormones work but like yes it is so
informational and so just for people so
they can go into it if they want but yes
kashup is brilliant
we're having this conversation the other
night because of you thank you and
um he's like the most amazing person I
have so much respect for his work and
his mind and
um and he was saying well you know this
one part about how light works with DNA
and I said wait wait like you know I've
never heard I've never seen that in any
you know book on on DNA and and you know
Western science and he's like oh that's
because it's not there
it was like it's it's it's only what the
elite would know and I was just like you
guys were getting words I said the words
you just said I've been saying those
words for 10 years Building Bridges of
light from the biological DNA to the
Divine genome within subatomic Universe
of our genetics and so that was an
extraordinary moment for me and it's
really hathor that you know being Guided
by hathor that kind of
initiated me to have the courage to come
forward with those teachings at a time
where I knew I could improve it like I
still don't I still can't prove it but I
know that it's true and I know that it's
real because I risked everything to
share that message with the world you
know there's a great there's a great
scene in um Contact the movie and it's
where Jody Foster and Matthew
McConaughey like ones she's all science
and he's all spirituality and he's
challenging her and he says did you love
your dad because her dad died when she
was young and she goes of course and he
goes prove it
um
and you can't like what how are you
gonna prove you love your dad or your
mom or your someone like yeah you can't
you just know it you just freaking know
it
well it's funny you brought up that
example because it was my love for
Humanity that
Humanity's future that you know I how
could I say no to the Master's request
to share that information it was because
of love that I I risked being a fool to
share that with the world and
you know what I love about hathor is
that I believe hathor's teachings within
Sofia code are really getting us ready
for Interstellar communion with beings
of the highest light
um not not the beings that are currently
oppressing the planet but but our our
star Families Our ancient families from
across the Multiverse that are just
waiting for enough of humanity to wake
up that we can
have that deep Tundra communion right
with all that is including other species
that are extremely enlightened and ready
to such as the hathor Star Nation that
are ready to help us step into a much
brighter future
so
um and it should be said too that the
book is has key code DNA activations
like things that you say out loud not
only reading the book is an activation
but maybe go into that just a little
just so people know that as we're
talking about DNA I mean think of people
just like for a second just go we are
all energy if you put all the people on
the planet together and put together
their actual matter I just heard I when
I interviewed Dylan deGrasse Tyson he
said you know whatever size Apple the
other day I heard it was the size of a
sugar cube the point is all the human
beings actual real matter put together
on the planet is freaking nothing we are
Just Energy so now go into please just
like like just what the the role of the
activations yeah so in my really early
Journey
um when I was in uh College I was
studying computer programming for
animation and Design
yeah yeah I have a my degree is in is in
you know web and branding and and
actually animation and
um
and I always wondered like okay am I is
this am I supposed to go deeper and
deeper into this back you know program
hard coding and
um and I and I got the message no and I
was like but why why am I so interested
in it and they were like it'll be
revealed you know down down the road
so when I first saw the Divine genome
you know all these years in seclusion
meditating with the ascended masters
I realized that the Sophia code was
actually hard-coded it needed to be
initiations that were hard coding to
literally flip on the switches that
would connect the Divine genome to the
carbon-based DNA and that the Brilliance
of the Sophia Dragon tribe was that they
wanted people to do this through the
power of their own voice oh I just got
chills because the the power of your own
voice is actually what activates Your
Divine genome this this bridge of light
connection these crystalline bridges of
light that you can consciously connect
and not only connect but they become a
super highway
for the Divinity of your higher self to
start downloading like an operating
system into the interface of the Divine
genome with then is now connected as
versions of light to the human body and
because it's crystalline there's no
amount of light it's like an infinite
amount of light that can be downloaded
into your body and over time this is why
Saints starts to literally like glow
right like you see pictures of like
Ananda moima and she's like glowing or
paramahansa Yogananda and they look like
there's light coming out of their skin
it's because there is they they found a
way to activate their Divine genome and
and this this technology has the power
to Anchor and an infinite amount of God
Source light in your body and we all
have this power we all have this
potential and so what they showed me is
the throat chakra you know the power of
your throat chakra the resonance which
mother Mary talks about in actually
hathor's chapter so we're still talking
about hathor has the power on this
bottom victory of your throat chakra
two um it's what creates reality through
the power of your voice this one little
petal at the bottom of your throat
chakra stop it the resonance that comes
through your voice through this one
little part of your throat chakra and
that resonance
um you know when you start to that's why
hathor and the Sofia code is called she
of a thousand voices which she is
attempting to to activate within
humanity is that we all have this voice
to create reality
and so when we start to notice and feel
the shifts of the Divine genome
operating our human body and our human
awareness in new ways then we make the
Cognitive Connection oh my God I did
that
I'm Sovereign if I can do that what else
can realize your power yeah and so these
initiations do two things simultaneously
they initiate Your Divine genome which
then starts an operating system that
simultaneously starts clearing viral
programming and Trauma from all your
lifetimes simultaneously while also
Begins the downloading process of your
higher self within every cell of your
body no big deal kind of the everything
and it's like it and then there's this
reinforcement of the each of these
ascended masters as you complete their
initiation they're saying I now commit
to you as a mentor and a spiritual guide
for what it's going to take to live in
these Divine qualities that you're now
going to go on a journey of embodying in
your daily life and so
um that's what's happening and the
recordings of the initiations help
reinforce and help you deepen and
integrate and accept the Divine genome
operating your awareness your ego
because what happens is you have to go
through an ego structure meltdown right
like it's got to start yeah they're fun
yeah it's got to start to integrate with
the light of your higher self and that's
why people start a spiritual journey and
they're like and then they end up giving
up because this is miserable it's too
hard right yeah it's not all [__]
puppies and rainbows no they are skulls
and flaming swords involved in a true
Spiritual Awakening and meltdowns like
like Rising Phoenix man over and over
again
so when you invoke that much light you
you also are becoming more aware of the
darkness that's been waiting for you to
see inside of yourself and so these
initiations really start the process of
allowing enough light to come and
override the ego structures demands on
your awareness and what you're going to
do with your life and it starts to break
the chains of the programming that would
have you forget who you are and start
the process of remembering who you
really are so
it's not any surprise that they put
Green Tara after hathor because
Green Tara who ascended in the star
system serious and then was invited by
the Divine mother to help shut like
oversee Humanity's Awakening on this
planet
um she is a total expert on how to
overcome the ego structure and how
devastating the ego structure and how
Wily it is it can you know what it takes
to outwit it through love self-love and
self-compassion and so
she's extraordinary I could talk about
Tara for hours but um for the sake of
time
um she helps us really see both our
Sovereign potential and our attachments
to suffering and
her Angelic order are called the kidneys
and they're often like these pictured of
these radical wrathful deities divine
feminine Buddhas that come forward to
protect you from you
to protect you from your own sabotage so
if you call on Green Tara to to help guy
to be your guide to help you in this
journey she's going to send Extra
Protection
yeah I mean she alone is right
larger I mean she's called the mother of
all Buddhas but that says anything
so you know it's like all of Buddhism
came from Tara's arrival to this planet
it didn't it's amazing how much the
divine feminine gets kind of written out
of it all right exactly every foot is a
guy right yeah well and and and and and
you know they do teach the zucchinis are
a female Buddhas but it's amazing kind
of
I won't go into all of that I want to
stay really positive but what I love
about Tara and then dakini's and the
Sofia code is the full Reclamation of
the divine feminine transmission that
gave birth to Buddhism on this planet
there it is yeah there it is plain and
simple there it is so
um and then we move into mother Mary
right and each of these Kiko initiations
are connected to a chakra so here we
have mother Mary at the heart chakra
and mother Mary is the spiritual mother
that we've always wanted we meet her in
the Sofia code free of religious
Doctrine for you dogma and what people
don't know about Mother Mary they think
of mother Mary's like this little girl
in a major scene right
I think mother Mary gets to speak like
four times in the Bible at the most and
it's not much
um
and the truth is that mother Mary was
initiated into the mysteries of very
early age her mother was an extreme High
Priestess of hathor she was an oracle
Anna
um hi hi Praises of hathor trained in
Egypt and so Mary was born to one of the
most powerful oracles on the planet at
that time
her mother knew
exactly who she was giving birth to and
she gave birth to Mary Mary was an
extraordinary orator she she was a
Divine feminist speaker yeah it's like a
speaker of the highest level
um divine feminine teacher of the
greatest Mysteries of the heart
um you know her mentors in communion and
Tantra communion and her psychic
development or Isis and hathor and Green
Tara and Kuan Yin I mean she led a
mystery school with her mother that
trained you know Jesus and Mary
Magdalene I mean not saying something an
entire community that you know embraced
them and their Ministry it wasn't just
Jesus and Magdalene and Mary that were
you know changing transforming the world
there were so many initiates embodying
their Divinity at that time and
um and that's you know she was a
spiritual mother to marry me Mary
Magdalene was so fiery you know yeah she
was like the Indigo she's like the
Indigo the ascended Master World she's
just like I don't you know she wanted to
break all the rules you know she just
wanted to go right after the Roman
Empire you know with all of her psychic
gifts and burn everything down and of
course like she just had that Kalima
sekhmet righteous rage for her people
and that's how we meet her in her
chapter just this
raw beautiful powerful areas yeah it
must have been right
she was just um
she was just wow she was a while and uh
you know I love that the Sofia code
talks about her relationship with Mother
Mary and that there was this true like
spiritual
Legacy between
magdalene's family mother Mary's family
Jesus and Magdalene there's Anna like
this connection to Egypt Tibet and and
India and
um so Magdalene is
we get to meet Mary Magdalene as
Magdalene like of course Jesus is there
and their Ministry is there but what's
so important to me about how we meet
Magdalene and the Sofia code is we get
to meet her
so many people introduce Magdalene in
context to the other
how she is defined by her relationship
to Jesus how is she defined by her
relationship with her sexuality it's
like in the Sofia code she's defined for
the woman that she is as the angel in
human form that she is as you know
as the head of a movement
totally transform the world yes
alongside the ha you know someone else
who is the head of a movement as well
they Collide a movement of Grace and
lightning and thunder and Consciousness
radical Consciousness and so she teaches
us that we are all awakeners of that
same Consciousness and that we've got to
be willing to embody that same Angelic
light that they did that she actually
shares in Sofia code we are a
continuation of their mission and if you
are attracted to Mary Magdalene is
because you've been a Magdalene for many
many lifetimes like Magdalene is a title
it's those Souls that are willing to
bring their light into the darkest of
places for their radical transformation
and Awakening of a species and so Mary
Magdalene helps us open our angel wings
and own them love her oh God and
everything else that goes along with it
I mean each of them are like a whole
universe of a wealth of resources I'm
trying to sum them up Kuan Yin
I
I don't know I don't know which is I I
venture to say it's my most favorite
chapter in the Sofia code it reads um it
reads like a movie
and we meet Kuan Yin as a child
um
when her Village is attacked
and she is
um
raped and tortured and her family is
killed in front of her
and her Village is burned to the ground
that's where we meet kuanian
and then we go on a journey with her
into the jungle of her grief
where
her Divine masculine encounter part
appears
to help awaken the divine feminine
Christ Consciousness within her
and what it took for her to heal
in the witnessing of the Divine
masculine on this journey of self-love
self-compassion painful self-compassion
painful embracing of the full journey of
healing from trauma into Soul power
and then what happens at the end where
she he ascends in front of her and then
she gets to become this Larger than Life
teacher of compassion true and authentic
Awakening to compassion the power of
that compassion and she teaches in the
Sophia code she is here to Mentor those
divine feminine leaders that are here in
this lifetime that are here to lead
through authentic self-compassion for
themselves first so this diamond of
compassion teachings is Diamond vehicle
from Kuan Yin comes in at key code six
we've got this building of like you know
Isis and hathor and green tar like super
powerful and let's go and mother Mary is
like let's open your heart and get into
here and magdalene's like get into your
leadership and all of a sudden
we're staring eye to eye with Kuan yin
and all this inner child healing and
this Kiko's sixth initiation where your
inner child
flows down this River to meet Kuan Yin
under this beautiful
um willow tree
and you have this trees oh my God and
you have this huge conversation an
activation of the Phoenix child oh my
god this is my chapter
with the Invincible innocence
this is like a Rising Phoenix painting
this is then this is for you right the
the Invincible innocence within you that
was never touched or harmed by anything
that you have survived in this lifetime
you feel that too don't you I mean
that's probably why it's one of your
favorite chapters yeah I mean it was one
of the hardest chapters for me to
surrender into because that was I I had
so much healing from everything I
survived and the first half in my life
and
um
and yet it's I think it's the most
beautiful it's it's uh
that to meet your Phoenix child and to
realize that that it is the master of
light that you are invoking within you
like it is your future
self it is your ascended Master self
that always existed within you that
could survive anything without your soul
you know being taken from you source of
your sovereignty and your Purity that
can never be touched
so this chapter is where most people
like totally break down and weep and
have the biggest breakthroughs of their
life and and and what I love about this
is that it really I think there's a lot
of people out there thinking that they
can just do this spiritual Divine
Purpose leadership rah-rah thing like I
don't know like you know from like a
headspace where if we just achieve
enough we'll get there
but
it's this is a like an authentic path of
spiritual weakening has to be from that
genuine space of where you know the most
broken places within you
which is hard to go to
because it's from that place that you
can compassionately serve anyone
no matter what they have survived no
matter how triggered their egos are you
can see yourself in them because you are
brave enough to love the one within you
that that once reacted or once you know
did the same things that someone else is
doing right in front of you it's like
leadership is service
and spiritual true authentic Spiritual
Awakening is Awakening to the truth that
we're here to love one another the way
Jesus taught
you know to really see each other's
potential means we gotta hold the line
and hold the bar high for each other
yeah and when people say I am my trauma
we have to say no you're not no you're
more than your trauma and that's what
kuanian mentors are saying yeah and I
know it because I lived it I'm not
asking you to believe me because I
didn't go within to find out from myself
you know Quan Yin brings some humility
then into into the picture that I think
is is a beautiful Temperance to how ex
to the unlimited power that we're
accessing here in the Sophia code um
within our hearts and our divine genome
and White Buffalo Woman comes in at the
at key code seven and holy smokes
um like channeling that chapter I took a
lot I took many years of training in the
Native American Church to understand why
white buffalo women had come and asked
me to
to do this and I include her why did she
well for starters she's the only
ascended master in this planet that is
native to this planet so you're saying
that all the other ascended masters they
come from other star systems mother star
systems
so she came from this star system where
she started her journey on this planet
she's like a she's like a combo she's a
combo
kind of like an archangel Fender being
slash ascended Master because she does
touch she has touched down in human form
therefore we can oriented is she more
like planetary nature
oriented or is she he's a master of the
source of original Source teachings
found within every indigenous culture on
the planet
so she's overseeing
the treasure
of Earth of Earth wisdom that is
absolutely essential essential for
Humanity's Ascension
this was her like uh when they say Gaia
like the planet like
um what what is her relationship with
with the Earth's consciousness
well I mean she's a part of
tending to its ecosystem
she's a part of
protecting
the heart of mother earth like the
spiritual consciousness of Mother Earth
and communicating the wisdom and
um and also she's part of an Angelic
order that we call in the Sofia go the
order of Sky grandmothers is extremely
Ancient Ancient Ancient ancestors that
have been watching over the Earth's
Ascension like we as a species have an
Ascension path but so does the Earth
okay yeah yeah the planet has its own
Ascension Journey as well what's
panchamama
well that that would be connected to the
traditions of yeah how they were would
refer to the Earth and the Earth
lineages in in South America Central
America
many names for the same Consciousness
um so
yeah
one of the things that that white
buffalo women
um initiates Us in in the Sofia code is
stepping into the power of a Christ
admission
so one of the weirdest things that
happened to me in the Sofia code was the
cinemasters kept saying they wanted me
to use the word Christ for Christ's
Consciousness in the book and I was like
I don't want to do that that's so
religiony
like please don't make me do that I feel
so uncomfortable with that
um and so I I would write it in but I
kept reserving the the right to
eventually find another word or edit it
out or I don't know I just I just kept I
there was such a resistance there and it
was actually White Buffalo Woman
oh my God I'll never forget this
so there's a teacher
um
a coded teacher who was named Black Elk
and um he shares his version of white
buffalo women's
um return or
visit to his people where she brings the
sacred pipe to Earth physically descends
from heaven and there's this whole story
um
that was passed down for per Generations
when I was reading through it in his
book The Sacred pipe
I was like wait a minute everything
about this story is Messianic it
literally has all the same Christian
principles of a messiah figure
prophecies that must come true
for that Messianic Messenger to fulfill
the prophecies that they spoke and
here's the thing her prophecies came
true her prophecy was that in the age
that her Consciousness would Return to
the Planet The White Buffalo would
appear upon the Earth as an emanation of
her grace and in our lifetime The White
Buffalo
which are an entirely new genetic
species have appeared upon the planet
they're not albino they're not bred to
be there are at least 20 truly totally
new genetic White Buffalo on the planet
held by Cynthia Golden Bear now I know
why you love white buffalo so much yeah
and I've had the Good Fortune of meeting
them and working with Cynthia and they
are truly prophecy animals and so white
buffalo said to me she said look my
people the the First Nations people were
genocided in the name of Christianity
and there is no greater Reclamation for
people to understand the Holiness of my
teachings than to talk about them in
terms of Christ Consciousness because
that's exactly what I've been teaching
all along and so there was this really
interesting language Dynamic that came
in where she was like I need people to
understand that the iraqular
languaging of mystical Christian
tradition which is you know
predates the organized Roman religion
the oracular
things that we look to in Mystic
initiations is exactly what white
buffalo woman's appearance and her
teachings that she brought to the people
as well as her Ascension and her
prophecies coming true they're literally
like they follow the formula of what is
prescribed in Mystic judaic tradition
for a messiah figure and that just blew
my hair back I was just like whoa okay
so what is White Buffalo women really do
in here she's initiating us into our our
own
Sovereign Christ Hood we are all
christed beings in the eyes of God we
are all Divine
and so or you could say Buddha beings
that are Awakening to the truth of our
of our our true nature and so she really
um she's really about the collective
Mission so by the time you reach key
code seven if you get that far I wish I
hope hope you do
um it's like game on you are wondering
what is my Divine Purpose and how am I
here to serve so in the final in the
eighth initiation which is actually key
code 777
um
I wonder why it took seven years to
download those huh really and you're
summing it up in a short amount of time
40 minutes oh my gosh
we meet the holiest seraphim of the
Divine mother we meet these Angelic
beings and the Kabbalah the seraphim are
called the fiery creatures of God
and I knew and I found that piece of
information because it was really
extraordinary for me to see
these angelic
holy creatures that were dragons they
weren't dragons connected to this world
they weren't dragons connected to any
Planet they were
these holy creatures of God that were
singing at the Throne of the Divine
mother's Consciousness whatever that in
that space
where the nothingness the no thing the
black womb of no thing turns into the
light of creation that to me is the
heart the Sacred Heart of divine mother
and at that place that's where those
seraphim are singing
an assisting creation
to come into form according to a Divine
will
and so they are initiators of our
Consciousness to recognize that we have
the power to co-create with Divine will
and to live as Jesus taught in this
world but not of this world fully
activated and living in our Highest
Potential to create a new Sovereign
reality because Dragon medicine yeah
it's like
dragons are masters of both Heaven and
Earth it's so appropriate that this
energy is coming in at this time to help
us overcome the luciferian interstellar
war that we're facing like we would need
protectors we would need activators at
this level of sovereignty if you like
this clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen